(soft upbeat music)
- Am I too old to wear this?
- No.
Does this make me look like I'm pregnant?
- Should I post this?
- [Blonde Woman] So cute, but no.
Oh my god, how embarrassed will Dee be
if I get up and do a cheer right now?
- (Gasps) Do it.
- Ready? Okay.
(laughing)
How funky is your chicken.
- Oh, should I have another baby?
- Oh.
Will I ever sleep again?
- Do you think I can breastfeed in this?
- Should I start working out?
- You think I should go
stop 'em from fighting?
- Probably.
- Guys.
- Do my nipples look like pepperoni?
- Can you still see my spit-up stain?
- It's perfect.
(laughing)
- Oh my god, did I just pee?
Is Dee into that awful gummy bear song?
Do you ever wish you didn't have kids?
- No.
- Me neither.
(soft upbeat music)